russia could be getting ready for war
[Applause]
it's amassed military equipment and
combat-ready troops along its border
with eastern ukraine so is vladimir
putin about to invade
we saw a similar military buildup in
april 2021. there's always been a
military base here but it is massively
expanded in the last few weeks from the
satellite imagery there are more than
500 military vehicles currently based
here from us just driving past it would
appear that there are even more tensions
lessened after a summit between joe
biden and vladimir putin but russia did
not seem to pull back its troops as
promised
we've seen this playbook before
in 2014 when russia last invaded ukraine
russia seized the peninsula of crimea
from ukraine in 2014 the first land grab
in europe since the second world war
and fueled an ugly war in the dombass
region of eastern ukraine between
russian-backed separatists and ukrainian
forces a war which still ticks on with
14 000 lives already lost
russia has always claimed that it's not
a party to that conflict and it refuses
to engage with ukraine's president
vladimir zilensky to try and resolve the
issue
that's because for vladimir putin the
problem is not so much president
zielenski but the western powers which
support him politically and militarily
partners
foreign
the kremlin is not just worried about
the possibility of ukraine being
admitted to nato but also that nato is
already so involved in bolstering
ukraine
the us has provided ukraine with more
than two and a half billion dollars
worth of military aid since 2014
including lethal weapons like javelin
anti-tank missiles
britain has just signed a deal that will
help ukraine buy british warships and
missiles
and ukraine continues to partner with
the us and other nato countries in
conducting training and military drills
on its territory and in the black sea it
is only ukraine
and 30 nato allies that decides when
ukraine is ready to join nato russia has
no veto russia has no say and russia has
no right to establish a severe influence
trying to control their neighbors
vladimir putin disagrees
in 2021 he wrote that ukraine and russia
were one people a single hole but the
ukraine now is under the control of
external forces who are intent on
turning ukraine into a barrier between
europe and russia a springboard against
russia that's why he wants security
guarantees from the us to stop nato's
eastwood enlargement or the placing of
missile defense systems near russia's
borders
security guarantees that president biden
is unlikely to give
[Music]
by u.s estimates russia will be ready
for a full-scale offensive by early 2022
and russia's foreign minister sergey
lavrov has given a pretty stark warning
to the west but war is certainly not
inevitable and if russia did invade it's
hard to see what vladimir putin would
hope to achieve
full-scale invasion would be incredibly
bloody and keeping hold of territory
where the people are largely hostile to
russia would be extremely difficult
plus there's nordstream 2 a gas pipeline
that would bring russian gas to germany
and other european countries that's
complete but waiting on regulatory
approval
it's hard to see europe giving that the
go-ahead if putin invades ukraine
plus there's the threat of further and
much tougher economic sanctions though
they have never stopped russia before
russia has just launched what it calls
regular winter training drills in its
southern military district in the region
bordering eastern ukraine and in crimea
but military exercises can easily spill
into the real thing
and whatever putin's planning even if
he's not yet sure of the endgame himself
his troops are well prepared